[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN LAKE: What if you
had a Google engineer
to support your app development?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Enabling
you to build better apps!
IAN LAKE: We've got you covered.
MALE SPEAKER 2: First, it
should work great on both square
and round devices.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: We wanted
to build a design system that
felt at home on every screen.
Refined typography, geometric
iconography, bold color.
IAN LAKE: I can't
tell you how critical
this is for making a
modern-looking Android app.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So keep
calm, profile your code,
and always remember,
perf matters.
MALE SPEAKER 3: We have
over a billion users
from over 190 countries.
MALE SPEAKER 4:
Android Marshmallow
is harmless and lovable-- that
could never possibly run amok
in New York and destroy us.
MALE SPEAKER 5: I'm
going to show you
how to extend your existing
music application to work
with Android Auto.
WOJTEK KALICINSKI: If
you've ever spent days
chasing a bug in your code--
MALE SPEAKER 6: Recognize this?
GENE TRINKS: Do you carry
around one phone for work
and another phone
for personal use?
Do you wish you
could just carry one?
ALL: Three, two, one!
Woo!
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Go
little balloon, go!
You can do it!
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: We are
Casa de Balloon Club.
MALE SPEAKER 5 (HIGH PITCHED):
And this was made with Android.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]